COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I take a look at some tools to
test Google Cloud Platform's
networking performance.
Will we find the
perfect multitasker?
Stay tuned to find out.
Over the past few
weeks, we've been
peppered with all sorts
of performance questions
centered around
networking and how
to configure GCP to get
the best possible results.
Now we've got a couple of videos
talking about some developers
that we were able to help.
But before that, I
wanted to take a moment
and talk about some of the
tools available to profile
GCP's networking so that you
don't have to write that code
yourself.
First is Netperf, which
is a commonly used tool
for measuring maximum TCP and
UDP bandwidth performance.
Netperf works by hosting
a server and a client
on different machines and
can measure the throughput
between the two ends,
either unidirectionally
or bidirectionally.
When you execute the client,
it connects to the server
and sends a boat
load of data around.
Now, once you install
Netperf, the server version,
called Netserver, will
be run automagically.
So you just need to pick which
instance will be the client
and execute the Netperf
binary to get the details
on the bandwidth conditions.
Iperf is a TCP
and UDP benchmark,
and has several
advantages over Netperf,
like bandwidth shaping
and threaded support
so that multiple
streams can be created.
Getting Iperf working is
somewhat straightforward.
Simply install Iperf on each
of your target instances
and run the server on one
and the client on the other.
What we get is an
output from Iperf
is a timed stamped report of
the amount of data transferred
and the throughput measure.
Now while Iperf
and net stats can
help you track latency
and throughput,
the Traceroute tool is useful
for measuring and displaying
the route that packets
take across the network.
It records the
history of the route
as well as a roundtrip time
of three packets received
from each successive
host in the route.
If you'd like to see
this for yourself,
run Traceroute on
your home machine.
Here's my result,
when you can see
that the first hop to the
ISP is significantly slow
given our distance
from that service.
Meanwhile, check
out the distance
between a VM running on Google
Compute Engine and google.com.
Much less hops.
Now once you have
the tools, it's
important to address
another issue--
how to properly test things.
This can be a tricky
problem since setting up
the wrong tests can lead to
inaccurate results, which
isn't something you want to
be making decisions off of.
This is exactly why Google
maintains the PerfKit
Benchmarker project.
Its authors have done
the due diligence
to set up their testing
harness correctly
and reduce the inserted error
that might skew the results.
So if you're serious about
testing your performance,
it's worth playing around with.
Now if you're interested in
a few more details, including
some gotchas with the firewalls
to get these tools working
on Compute Engine,
check out the article
for this video in the
description below.
And if you want to get more
great Cloud Performance
content, check out
the rest of our videos
because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]